en marche pour l'elysée tout un
programme pour jet ce jardinier de 55
ans il a décidé d sillonner les routes à
pied pour rencontrer emmanuel macron
après deux jours de manifestations à
chalon le week-end dernier il n'a pas
réussi à déposer son gilet jaune je
senti qu'on avait fait si je continuais
pas ça allait s'arrêter là une flamme
qui s'est rallumée il fallait pas
qu'elle se teignent donc j'ai décidé de
faire la grève de la faim et de faire le
nécessaire pour que ça continue
le nécessaire une grève de la faim est
un périple de 330 km à pied ils espèrent
attirer l'attention du président pour
lui parler des souffrances des français
avec ou sans gilet quitté personnes qui
travaillent sur le salaire elles doivent
ordonner une grand partie à l'état dans
les taxes dans les impôts et ne reste à
peine à certains à peine pour survivre
la lutte
ils ont décidé de l'amener au-dessus de
la rca retraités chômeurs travailleurs
ils étaient une cinquantaine pour eux
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence a
été la goutte d'eau de trop
on nous demande encore de nous serrer la
ceinture alors que bon en haut lieu on a
régulièrement des scandales financiers
et des politiques qui s'en mettent plein
les poches et et il ya une injustice
grandissante les retraites maintenant
cdd des gens qui vivent avec 680 euros
expliquez moi comment on peut vivre
aujourd'hui en france avec 680 moi je
dis voulait racheter les papis et les
mamies mon boulot il ya des gens
aujourd'hui qu'ils mangent deux repas
par semaine parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de s'en payer plus de tous bords
politiques c'est gilet jaune se disent
prêts à aller jusqu'au bout
connais pas
la plus marche ou crève je pense qu'on
n'a plus rien à perdre le long des
routes automobilistes et routiers
étaient très nombreux à montrer leur
soutien